Speaker 1: Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
has become very comfortable in the right wing
propaganda bubble where you're just allowed to
kind of say really whatever you want, and it's
not really challenged in any way. And he was very
triggered when he appeared on CNN. And Dana Bash,
quite honestly, very gently pushed back against
like one little tiny corner of what he was saying
about abortion. And he didn't like it one bit.
He didn't like being questioned in any way and
attacked her, saying, you're covering for these
people. There's actually some really interesting
data underlying what they're talking about,
about abortion. So let's listen to it. Let's
look at it, then I'll talk to you more.
Speaker 2: I think the Republican Party
will be in good standing to oppose late term
abortion like most of the civilized world.
Speaker 3: Just for the record, Roe went up
to viability. But I just want to button this up.
Speaker 2: The No, no, no quick coverage for these
guys. What? No, no, no. Your media, you keep
covering for these guys. They introduced
legislation that allowed abortion on demand.
What taxpayer funded were you paying for it,
the taxpayer, up to the moment of birth. That
was their position in Washington. That's the
law they want to pass. And nobody in your
business will talk about it. It's barbaric.
Speaker 3: Senator, I'm not covering for
anybody and you know that. And when I have
Democrats on and I've had Democrats.
Speaker 2: I've asked for the facts.
Speaker 3: I have asked many all of
them about their position on where
where they believe this issue should be.
Speaker 1: Okay. The temper tantrum by
Lindsey Graham accusing Dana Bash of covering for
them just because she inserted one little measly
fact into the discussion that is a result of the
propaganda bubble that the Republican Party is so
used to. It's really important to understand two
parts of this. First of all, Dana Bash is correct.
The Supreme Court decision in 1973 in Roe v Wade
established that a woman has a constitutional
right to terminate a pregnancy up to the point
of fetal viability, which is generally around
24 weeks of gestation. Since Roe v Wade. With
medical advances, there have been very limited
instances where a fetus was able to survive a week
or two earlier than that. Insanely rare, insanely
risky. But what we are talking about here, indeed
with Roe v Wade, which is gone now. Okay. But
Dana Bash is correct. This isn't controversial.
Roe v Wade dealt with the point of viability,
generally considered 24 weeks. But there's
another really important thing to understand.
Abortions in general. After 21 weeks, forget
about 24 after 21 weeks are really rare.
Difficult to get. Costly time intensive and only
even performed by some providers. Now it doesn't
matter what you think is right or wrong. The point
is something that barely happens gets almost all
of the attention, and the vast majority of
abortions get almost no attention. There's
a very good graphic from the CDC, which we're
going to put up on the screen, which shows that
more than a third of abortions are before six
weeks. Remember, it usually takes five weeks to
even know you're pregnant. 34% of abortions are
before six weeks. A full 52% of abortions are
before seven weeks. And then you stack up the
numbers. 99% of abortions are before 19 weeks.
And when you look out at this graph and you look
all the way out to 29 weeks, 0.01% of abortions
are happening at that point. And if you go beyond
19, beyond 29 weeks, it is statistically zero. So
Lindsay is upset that Dana Bash said, oh, Roe v
Wade dealt with up until the point of viability.
What she should have said is Lindsay, 91%
of abortions happen before 13 weeks. 99%
of abortions happen before 19 weeks or some
formulation of that. Based on the CDC data.
But they don't care. They don't want to talk
about that. And instead they want to talk about
two days before the due date, a week after the
due date and all of these different things. Now,
let's divide that up into two parts just so
we're being thorough. The after birth abortions.
I still am not totally sure where that comes from.
It's not anywhere. There was a rumor from New York
that they started. It was untrue. There was a
rumor from Virginia. They started. It was untrue.
So after birth abortion, it's not even worthy
of our discussion. The day before the due date.
Abortion. Really precise statements about this
were made in some abortion hearings. I want to say
it was about a year ago, maybe a year and a half
ago. And OB-GYNs and other medical practitioners
testified under oath about this. And they said,
listen, just because it might be legal somewhere
to have an abortion in the third trimester
doesn't mean that Obis are just going to do it.
And that it doesn't mean that people are coming
to us asking for that. And multiple OBGYN said
it's never even come up in my practice. This
scenario of your 37 weeks pregnant and you say,
Hey, you know what? I think I just don't want
a baby. Oh, sure, we'll perform an abortion.
Most Obies have said it's not even come
up. The rare cases where that happens,
you're talking about the mother's life being at
risk and that it is just not a thing. The way
that Republicans pretend that it is. So anyway,
Lindsay's all triggered because one little fact
was interjected. I wish Dana Bash had actually
said more and said, Why do you and your ilk insist
on focusing on a part of the curve that is below
0.01% of all abortions, which has been widely
discussed by OBIS, and we now understand the
truth of it. Why do you pretend like that's what
abortion is? But she didn't do that. And fine.
She didn't think it was her place to. But Lindsay,
Lindsay's got to settle down and get out of
that propaganda bubble a little more often.